[Musique]
dans les enfants pour ce soir bon choix
mais oui ce soir je vais raconter une
histoire à nikolay a pas pro d'elle une
histoire qu'ils aient beaucoup
d'humidité beatty dans le cher
du petit débit tb
bonsoir
ces cas là tu n'auras pas d'une histoire
oui une histoire de la petite philippine
et de son lapin blanc d'accord
un instant je me pose
là
écoutez bien noël monchy noël qui
approchent et tu contente philippines
oui et que tu demandé au père noël
tibi mon lapin blanc a répondu la petite
fille ronde et coquine retapant une
énergique ment sur son tambour
non
alors pour essayer de retrouver ce lapin
blanc qui n'était ni à la mer ni à la
campagne philippines et ses parents sont
partis à la montagne
[Musique]
la grande montagne
était recouverte d'une neige profonde
dans laquelle la petite philippine
s'enfonçait alors elle me des skis et en
compagnie de ses parents elle explore à
toutes les pentes de cette montagne mais
elle ne retrouvera pas son ami le lapin
blanc
mais le matin de noël elle trouva dans
ses petits souliers au milieu de tas de
joux une lettre nice terje
qui disait
à bientôt
des signes
typiques dit
je retrouverai mon lapin blanc je le
retrouverai s'écria philippines folle de
joie et s'est mis à jouer
et voilà les enfants l'histoire est
terminée vous l'avez aimée oui beaucoup
et bien je vous donne le livre merci de
nous cicala ça nous ont fait 12 toute
une collection la prison nous avons ri
sur petit
[Musique]
boni groen
9e nuit les enfants
fait pour eux
[Musique]
oh
du début du du bitume à paroles mais
c'est le lapin blanc melon patron ce
mois nounours hop hop hop hop au jeu
vous au piano tropez allons en route
gros phares sert venue des enfants en
bas c'est bien fort vos parents faites
votre toilette n'oubliez pas de vous
lever le don est fait pour
[Musique]